how's it going bros my name Wow welcome
to PewDiePie today we're gonna challenge
yourself got a bunch of rubber bands
last recording I did then I go so well
so I thought we're challenge I'll
challenge myself to become better at
this game so if I die or if I lose my
[ __ ] I'll put on a rubber band I don't
never wear in my body how about that
let's do this
the character is moving by itself what
the [ __ ] alright then - bunch door
where'd he go I think these rubber
prints aren't good looks great already
seeing I'm really determined not to die
so this means I will never die this is
really good I should have done this
sooner this is a great idea best idea
alright you need to come down down to
the ground what happened I check bite
see I'm really good at video games now
and I look like Nicki Minaj ah [ __ ]
hurts as hell but I'll put this one on
my wrist yeah but the [ __ ] here come
but look hard okay you know I'm just
gonna do if I swear how about that cuz
my face is gonna look like a fried
chicken if I a mother fine Mariah a book
it's ridiculous how much I swear like I
want to swear in every second ball play
in this game all right
then the [ __ ] comes here and he's like
stop aah
all right we got this press we got this
brows
this is for my brows why do you do it
why do you do this why you do these okay
here we go
scheisse
that's the swear words come on ha ha
okay oh and talk how am I supposed to do
it 8d Shh this is the ultimate torture
seriously you don't know pain until you
play this game okay all right yes yes
yes all right how do we do this you go
in here and then what [ __ ] it okay I got
this the checkpoint is right there the
t-talk anus
do I look how I look at that one
this is great I might choke to death hi
there is alright fun no come on I'll
wear my earring how about that I count I
think yet okay here we go
[Music]
so shovel uphill [ __ ] shower okay I'm
making up my own rules as I go because
this [ __ ] sucks checkpoints means I
can reset we did it a champ
I knew the Rope events would work they
make me try hard what dish actually sad
hello sir scope 360 good it's fat the
lord i'll excuse me words just pop out
of me sometimes there is a camel up
ahead who is smoking can you take it
away from it how do i right-click mixer
and you go and i'll catch you up ahead
see you laters noscope well that's a
great story
thanks for playing this Emma it makes us
your audience really happy what do you
play now is the most boring part of the
game so you can imagine how fun it will
be later on
so excited peered up pie - it's gotta be
the best if you want to suggest some
challenges I can do down below well led
to help improve my no scopez and feel
free to do so leave a like be one more
and as always thanks for watching
die awesome bros you said it would help
me what do I do
what do you want
[Music]